welcome to Chris Stockman's in-depth
retrospective on Toonami I'm Steve bloom
the voice of Tom enjoy the video friends
bang
[Music]
in the early 90s when I was in school it
was considered very uncool to like anime
it was a very niche medium of
entertainment in America very few people
knew about it and those who did probably
refer to it as japanimation and it
seemed forever destined to populate the
early morning of the sci-fi channel or
the lesser traveled aisles of comic book
stores sure there were many shows that
had reached American shores and some
films that garnered attention such as
ghost in the shell' an Akira but they
still weren't reaching a wider audience
and little respect was given to the
English dubbing process of some earlier
titles just getting him some tips about
driving hey I'll never forget one of my
first encounters of anime being popular
I was on the school bus and I would say
it was about in sixth grade all of these
kids were piled around this other kid
like he had found the first issue of
Superman or something one of the cool
kids had opened up his Trapper Keeper
and I was shocked to discover that he
was actually bragging about his
collection of Pokemon cards he was
showing off his rare foils and
everything within a matter of weeks it
was suddenly cool to like anime and I
was uncool because I didn't have any
Pokemon cards what's incredible to me is
that they are still immensely popular
today before filming this video I was
easily able to obtain these booster
packs at a store less than a mile away
from my house in America Pokemon
received early exposure in this may 1996
issue of Nintendo Power the Super
Famicom game from Japan was called
Pocket Monsters and there were two
variations of it the article stated that
some players are so enamored of Pocket
Monsters that they have purchased both
versions in order to own all the
monsters Nintendo Power had no idea that
within a short time they'd have a
section of their magazine entitled polka
Center dedicated entirely to the
franchise but on March 17 1997
everything changed forever
Cartoon Network debuted a new
programming block called tsunami it was
dedicated to bringing awesome
action-oriented cartoons to a younger
audience and nearly all of the shows
that they have aired have been anime in
the blocks prestigious history it has
literally inspired an entire generation
to appreciate art from another land its
original host was Malta from the show
Space Ghost some of the shows that
tsunami is responsible for popularizing
are Gundam Wing Yu Yu Hakusho
outlaw star Tenchi Muyo Sailor Moon
Rurouni Kenshin Ronin Warriors and of
course Dragonball Z I vividly remember
being bored out of my mind in class and
a kid who I was pals with leaning over
and saying hey are you watching
Dragonball Z I had no idea what he was
talking about but nevertheless I was
intrigued after school the first episode
I watched was called den day's demise
and from then on I was hooked I once
took a quiz that asked me what my
favorite part of school was I replied
that I could run home from it to watch
tsunami now back then I lived in a
pretty big apartment complex and the
school bus only dropped us off at the
entrance of said complex so I still had
about a mile to walk home and most of
that time was me running trying to get
home in time for tsunami to start
homework what was that I didn't know
what that was
tsunami was on probably not the best
monitor lived by bidet I was a kid I
became obsessed with DBZ my neighborhood
comics store is called JC comics and I
still go there to this day
the store owner has essentially seen me
grow up and we've gone from talking
about whatever the newest DBZ VHS tape
were release date is - how awesome
guardians of the galaxy was nothing has
really changed to be honest I used to
have a massive DBZ VHS collection as
seen here which have now been upgraded
to the recently released blu-rays wait a
second
look at my old computer dear lord i
religiously read the manga collected
countless toys had temporary tattoo
books which by the way still
working tats I even made some comics of
my own
complete with hand-drawn panels to pile
on the nerd even more my friends and I
had our own Dragon Ball Z Club in which
we would host pseudo battles between
ourselves we build up our powers list by
completing certain tasks in real life
and then we'd have those battles and if
we did really well throughout the week
we could unleash a Kamehameha wave and
defeat our friends I love my childhood
my first introduction to Dragon Ball Z
was just walking up to the Funimation
studios and they had all these posters
that they've gotten from Japan and I
don't think anybody really knew who
everyone in the entire cast was but I
remember staring at the posters going is
that Goku they're like no that's going
on and I goes that go 10 they're like no
that's that's Goku in GT so and then my
my second introduction to Dragon Ball Z
was them handing me a big old bag and
then telling me go watch all of this and
so I had to take it home and watch a bag
of video tapes of the entire frieza saga
and they only gave me a few days to do
it so I was just it was just torture
trying to get the risk so fast
interesting because I'd never
experienced anything quite like it
before like I'd never experienced a
serial anime before in my life I'd seen
ghost in the shell' I'd seen Acura but I
hadn't seen anything quite like that I
don't think it really sunk in for me
until I guess in 1999 we had a cast
party with all the initial Dragon Ball Z
actors in it we were at this bar called
Lana ganz I still remember the name and
we were all watching it run for the
first time on Toonami with a new cast
and that was insane like I'd never heard
my voice on TV before much less you know
on Dragon Ball Z and everyone was just
glued to the television watching and
cheering I would like to think that that
was my first true experience with Dragon
Ball Z because that was the time when it
finally sunk in that while we're doing
something crazy awesome
through the years due to tsunami I began
watching other great titles and
discovered many of the show's mentioned
earlier at first watching Ronin Warriors
or sailor moon' was simply because they
came on before DBZ but eventually I
became fans of those as well as outlaw
star and rurouni kenshin I'm ashamed to
admit it's just been in the past few
weeks that my wife has introduced me to
YuYu Hakusho but I'm loving it so far
how did you first discover it because I
didn't watch it back in the day I didn't
watch it on town I watched it on Toonami
the first time because I don't remember
watching it and I think it's because
most the time I was asleep but you said
that you used to watch Midnight Run
alright I always watched The Midnight
Run and what was one of the first things
we ever bonded over first time we talked
we talked about tsunami and our love of
Dragon Ball Z it was vastly easier to
record do you hakusho than it was Dragon
Ball Z to put in a perspective when we
started dumping Dragon Ball Z we were
dubbing into old archaic terrible
equipment that barely worked just barely
barely worked and working on uu we'd
already you know worked out a lot of the
kinks and the recording software and on
top of that when we started recording
Dragon Ball Z we had about eleven actors
on our actor list that we could trust to
do it I mean we're talking Sonny
straight Shawn Chimel myself by the time
we got to you you hakusho we had a you
know we at least we had some sort of
sizable cast list casting you you and
recording you you was a completely
different experience we'd already gone
through the war and it was just pretty
easy after that on July 10th 1999
tsunami introduced a new host named Tom
who hung out in space on his ship the
absolution introducing us to each show
this is around the time where Toonami
success skyrocketed and they were able
to do things called Total Immersion
events which were many stories taking
place during the breaks of the shows I
can remember being very excited for the
intruder which told the story of a
strange entity invading the ship this
concluded with a brand new Tom voiced by
the incomparable Steve bloom well I
think first and foremost tsunami gave
credibility to this art form
anime that prior to that time was very
difficult for the American palate and
those who did watch enemy or
japanimation as they called in those
days really we're intent on watching it
in its original form subtitled and what
we were doing was an aberration and I
was accused of ruining the art form
several times during my career so I
think one of the great gifts that
Toonami gave to America was showing them
that anime is a huge diverse universe of
animation that we had never seen before
unabashedly unafraid to address
situations like dysfunction the family
over violence or loneliness the things
that all of us go through separation not
fitting in those sorts of emotions that
so many of us go through in our early
years and some into our later years and
anime kind of created this community
where we all sort of felt we could have
a place and you go to conventions it at
this point and you see people dressed up
in costumes who live very normal
conservative lives for the most part and
they go to these conventions and that's
when they feel most free
that's what fans tell me that they can
be who they want to be they've got a
community who understands them it
doesn't judge them Toonami
was a huge gateway for that to happen
and continues to be to stay so I'm very
impersonally very grateful to to Nami
for giving hundreds of thousands if not
millions of people a place to go the
Midnight Run was soon introduced which
allowed Toonami to air more intense
entertainment from midnight to 5:00 a.m.
they even aired some of Daft Punk's
interstella 5555 and gorillas music
videos the Rising Sun was to Nami
Saturday morning block running from a
9:00 a.m. to noon this block was
particularly popular for airing the DBZ
garlic jr. saga three hours of
consider ourselves fortunate and it's
not even a school day to not may the
Rising Sun Saturday from 9:00 to noon
you just made my day a day victory
on April 17th 2004 Toonami mood from
weekdays to Saturdays and it's lineup
included Naruto one piece Dragon Ball GT
and shows produced in America like Teen
Titans and Justice League Unlimited
tsunami even did something called a
month of Miyazaki Aran castle in the sky
Nausicaa Princess Mononoke and spirited
away the amount of amazing entertainment
they've helped young audiences to
appreciate is astounding but on
September 20th 2008 tsunami was
unfortunately cancelled and the current
incarnation of Tom had this to say well
this is the end beautiful friends after
more than 11 years this is two mommies
final broadcast
a lot of fun and we'd like to thank each
and every one of you who have made this
journey with us tsunami would have been
anything about you hopefully we've left
you with some good memories so until we
meet again
Stay Gold
[Music]
dang I kept in touch with the guys in
Atlanta throughout that period we've
done a few of other little things
together but I never thought that we'd
actually get to go back on the air the
outpouring of support during tsunamis
hiatus was amazing the fans are rallying
there were websites that were dedicated
to bringing to Nonis back and grateful
to those guys because they kind of kept
it alive it was a very sad time for
anime fans and fans of tsunami in
general for years I participated in
petitions to revive the block and I even
started my own YouTube channel which was
one of my first youtube channels that
was entirely composed of my attempts to
recreate Toonami promos and it actually
did ok the channel is no longer up
anymore but here is a look at one of my
original promos
did he be so strong he's blocking my tax
like they were nothing by the super
now we'll seal the fate
[Music]
beneath me
our superiors abide by
playing in the universe then on April
1st 2012 Cartoon Network's highly
successful block Adult Swim did its
annual April Fool's Day joke and while
in the past that was generally an
all-night marathon of this so bad that
it's good classic the room for one night
they re aired classic shows from toonami
complete with the bumpers and everything
many people dubbed it the night know 90s
kids slept I remember getting that call
to do paper fools evening and how great
that felt even if we only got to do it
for one one night and to bring it to
know me back to its former glory for at
least that one night I remember getting
online that night I had some friends who
called me and texted me and said dude
there's there's a bunch of stuff going
on out there on the net you got to check
it out get on Twitter and I didn't have
it I don't even know if I had a Twitter
account at the time but I got on Twitter
that night and I stayed up all night
with the fans and it was crazy I think
the viewership that night went from
something like two hundred thousand
viewers the normal viewership to like
1.4 million and it really showed that
people cared about tsunami and wanted to
bring it back and that there was an
audience and we had concrete proof to
show the network I was just so excited
to be part of that wave it was really
fun it was really fun and I felt like I
had nothing to do with it personally he
was the fans brought it back so give
yourselves a pat on the back out there
you guys see you did an amazing thing
and kind of an unprecedented thing I
think so
thank you this sparked an even greater
demand for the block's return and
finally on May 16th 2012 it was
announced that on Saturday nights Adult
Swim would be taken over by Toonami
and a bevy of new shows like cash ran
sins samurai seven and Full Metal
Alchemist have been included in the
lineup and received widespread love they
even began airing Cowboy Bebop again
after Adult Swim initially helped
popularize it back in 2001 shows like
Inuyasha bleach and ghost in the shell'
stand alone complex are part of the new
lineup as well even now the show that
made Toonami famous in the 90s is back
this time however it's the filler list
DBZ
I know how it feels sometimes the world
can look bleak times can seem tough in
some days nothing's gonna go your way
but you can't let that break you down we
can't let that change who you are I'm a
lot of things but I'm not a quitter when
it comes to my dreams nobody puts dandy
in a corner you're gonna have to dig
deep and find that extra positivity to
keep the grind from grinding you when
everything seems against you no matter
how nasty this place may be you and me
are gonna fight our way through it or
being positive and helping somebody else
out there's a great power inside you
just waiting to be unlocked believe in
your abilitie there's one thing I'm sure
positivity will be your light in the
darkness now let's get back out there
and keep fighting the fight how does it
feel to be part of something that's so
positively shape lives
well humbling it never gets old and it
gives me a new center every time I hear
a fan tell me that tsunami was their
childhood and I hear that a lot these
days and my standard answer is we'll
look how great you turned out despite
that as irreverent as we were throughout
all the years and to know me we really
underneath it all we're delivering a
positive message and we were delivering
a great product so yeah I mean humbled
is probably the best word that we
describe being even just the smallest
part of any of that I will say one of
the the most incredible fan experiences
I had was talking to a guy who showed me
his arm and there was barely any of it
left really it was just this just
wrinkled up leathery skin over a small
bone and that was supposed to be like
his shoulder he told me that when he was
really young he's playing
hide-and-go-seek with his brothers and
sisters and friends and he ran through
the kitchen and poured by accident of
course a boiling pot of water all over
him
and he told me that it was the most
excruciating pain he'd ever had and he
was in the hospital for months and
months of in months with reconstructive
surgeries and he said that all he did
during that time was a watch Dragonball
Z and it was a something that was very
dear to him and it helped him get the
strength he needed to kind of keep going
and that one really got me and that one
really got me tsunami has been a major
part of my life even if you were a fan
of anime before Toonami came along it's
because of Toonami
that we've had the opportunity to see so
many other awesome animes in America
because they made people realize that
anime is something to be reckoned with
it's something that a lot of people can
enjoy and it's an art form that has
inspired countless filmmakers around the
entire world nowadays we gather around
our computers hoping to stream our
favorite shows but there was a time
period in the late 90s and early 2000s
where it felt like my entire world
stopped to watch tsunami my friends and
I would gather to discuss the latest
cliffhanger on DBZ and since the
internet was still in its relative
infancy it was considerably easier to
avoid spoilers from Japan since these
shows had all aired there already
I spent a large portion of my youth
drawing these characters and imagining
these worlds Who am I kidding I'm an
adult and I still do it the storytelling
of many of these shows helped me
understand a lot about action
entertainment and to appreciate
something that was from another land
without it I wouldn't be the same person
I am today just a special thank you to
Jason DeMarco Gil Austin and our old
buddy Shawn Aikens for creating Toonami
and bringing it back after all these
years to a whole new audience I'm really
grateful to you guys and to everybody at
Adult Swim and everybody on Williams
Street you guys have
have gone above and beyond to bring this
back to the audience and a lot of you
guys out there don't know that these
guys did a lot of this on their own time
and I'm talking about the the engineers
the post-production people everybody
involved in tsunami and and there are a
lot of them who did this stuff on their
own time because of the love of the
genre and because of the love of tsunami
and because of their love and respect
for you guys and so they really do care
and so thank you guys for bringing me
back on board and keeping Toonami going
for all these years very very grateful
stay cold bang guys thank you so much
for watching my inaugural episode of
retro rewind I'm gonna have a lot more
of this kind of stuff for you guys I've
never had more fun making a video ever I
thank you so much for watching it and I
have a special guest to sign this video
up you may recognize him his name is
Christopher sabot and he just so happens
to be the voice of Vegeta and piccolo
thanks guys oh look at all you pee on
zout there behind your worthless
computer screens look wait what is this
you're not stuck mine eyes yet oh you've
got to be kidding me I am the Prince of
all Saiyans and I command you to get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]